Could you take a baby step this way?
Was I blocking “Starry Night?”
Hello, and welcome.
My name is Anne Umland.
I’m a curator in the Department of Painting
and Sculpture here at The Museum of Modern Art.
I often get asked, “So just what is it that
you curators do all day?”
Curators are responsible for acquiring works
of art for the collection.
We discuss how to display those works.
When, where, why, how?
Some of you may have seen me in episodes of
“At the Museum”
or “How to See.”
And in response to those episodes, you’ve
sent in all sorts of great questions.
We thought we’d do a Live Q&A to answer
some of those questions.
Like, well, “how do you become a curator?”
Or “how do curators decide what works go
on view in a gallery or in an exhibition?”
Or “once you’ve decided what's
going to be in a given gallery, how should
it be framed?”
“How large should a pedestal be? How much space should you allow?”
Oh my goodness, this is one of my most favorite
galleries in the Museum.
I hope that you will submit some questions
down in the comments section.
You also will be able to post questions to
me live on April 24.
In advance of that, I’d encourage you to
subscribe to the Museum’s YouTube channel,
and there you’ll be able to check out some
of the other great videos that the team here has made.